Trascrizione: Giulia Sgarbossa
Revisore: Maria Pericleous
Grazie.
(Grida)
(Rumori indistinti)
Vedere queste immagini mi fa sempre
effetto, mi fa anche molta rabbia.
Una domanda che mi porto da tanti anni,
è sempre la stessa in ogni missione,
“e se fosse”.
E se fosse mia sorella,
se fosse mia mamma, mia figlia,
mio papà, mio fratello?
Sono Gennaro Giudetti e sono di Taranto.
Sono un operatore umanitario.
Sono tornato ieri dal Venezuela.
Ci tenevo a essere qui questa sera
per parlare della mia storia
e di quelle di tantissimi
operatori umanitari
che ci mettono la faccia nel mondo,
davanti a dei drammi del genere
che vengono causati spesso da persone
che decidono anche per noi
il nostro futuro.
Sono nato a Taranto
e sono partito circa dieci anni fa
per l’Albania, la mia
prima missione era lì,
dove lavoravo con i senza fissa dimora.
Vivevo lì come loro e con loro.
Da lì in poi il mio viaggio è stato
sempre un continuo senza fermarmi mai,
dall’Albania al Kenya.
Ho vissuto in Kenya nelle
baraccopoli con i ragazzi di strada,
ragazzi che morivano di fame, quindi
per mangiare andavano nella spazzatura
a rovistare per trovare qualche
tappo di bottiglia di plastica o di ferro
per venderlo a $2 o $3,
e mangiare per sopravvivere.
Quindi cercavamo di rimuovere
dalla strada questi ragazzi,
di portarli nella scuola
e fare un inserimento.
Tra questi bambini,
uno si chiamava Chimama
era un bambino molto irrequieto,
sembrava molto me.
Era molto arrabbiato
e non capivo il perché,
era sempre così incazzato col mondo.
Dopo qualche settimana
mi hanno detto che era così
perché ha visto sua mamma
morire bruciata viva.
Quando la gente rubava nelle baraccopoli,
la tradizione voleva che li legassero
nei copertoni e li bruciassero vivi.
Quindi aveva visto sua mamma bruciare così
e la persona che l’ha
bruciata era suo padre.
Quindi l’unica persona che gli era rimasta
era la persona che gli aveva
causato il dolore più forte.
Sono tornato in Kenya dopo qualche anno
per salutare i ragazzi e cercare Chimama.
Mi hanno detto che anche lui
ha fatto la stessa fine della mamma
perché aveva rubato
anche lui nella baraccopoli.
Quindi la legge non perdonava nemmeno lui.
Dopo di che mi sono spostato
in Kenya e da lì in Colombia
a supportare una comunità di pace.
Una comunità di pace di contadini che
hanno deciso di non scappare dalle terre,
di non coltivare cocaina
di non appoggiare il conflitto,
ma di vivere in pace.
Questo in Colombia costa,
costa anche la vita.
Sono morte più di 200 persone
della comunità di pace
e loro comunque tutti i giorni lottano
in maniera non violenta.
Al leader della comunità di pace
hanno ammazzato 11 familiari.
Anche questo fa pensare:
e se fosse... E se fosse...
Immaginate che vi ammazzino 11 parenti
non vi rimane quasi nessuno,
forse il vostro cane, non lo so.
Lui comunque mi parlava
di perdono, riconciliazione, pace,
dobbiamo costruire muri,
perché il fuoco non spegne il fuoco
quindi dobbiamo perdonare
il nostro nemico.
Sono entrati comunità di pace
dei paramilitari per ucciderlo.
Hanno disarmato e bloccato i paramilitari,
anche se li volevano ammazzare.
Il leader si è avvicinato ai paramilitari,
li avevano legati aspettando la polizia,
e ha detto: “Se avete fame o sete
vi diamo da mangiare e da bere.”
Ecco, una cosa che mi stupiva.
Erano più le domande che mi facevo
che le risposte che riuscivo a darmi.
Dopo un annetto così in Colombia,
mi sono spostato in Palestina,
anche lì un’altra un’altra resistenza.
Loro resistono e lottano nelle loro terre.
Era una comunità di contadini
e pastori palestinesi
che voleva costruire scuole
per i loro figli, per il loro futuro.
Perché i bimbi che vanno a scuola
attraversano delle colonie
e gli israeliani li picchiano
per non farli andare a scuola
e per disincentivare
l’uso di quelle strade.
Quindi hanno deciso di costruire
loro stessi una scuola per i loro figli.
Avevano però paura che fosse demolita
e quindi cosa facevano?
Di mattina costruivano le donne
e di sera gli uomini
perché per legge il soldato
non può fare questioni con le donne.
Quindi i soldati la mattina
trovano solo le donne,
la sera però gli uomini
continuavano a costruire la scuola.
La scuola adesso è costruita
e i bambini vanno a scuola.
Ecco un esempio di
resistenza popolare non violenta.
E dopo la Palestina
il mio viaggio continua
e mi sono spostato in Libano,
in Libano perché?
Il dramma dei profughi siriani
che scappavano in Libano.
Il Libano è un paese piccolino,
è grande più o meno quanto la Puglia.
Ci sono 4 milioni di abitanti
e 1,5 milioni di profughi.
Un po’ come se in Italia
ne arrivassero 20-30 milioni,
mentre noi gridiamo all’invasione
con 150.000 persone che arrivano.
Ho vissuto in un campo profughi.
Sono arrivato in un campo profughi
insieme ad altri ragazzi come me.
Lì abbiamo detto:
“Noi da oggi vogliamo vivere qui”.
Han detto: “Sappiamo che in Italia
c’è crisi ma non fino a sto punto”
No, vogliamo vivere qua per trasformare
i numeri che sentiamo tutti i giorni in tv
in persone, per noi erano dei volti.
Erano Muhammad, Ahmad,
Abdel, Salam, erano persone,
quindi trasformare i numeri in persone.
E’ ciò che dovremmo fare tutti.
Quando trasformi i numeri
che senti tutti i giorni in tv
in persone che muoiono
nel Mediterraneo o nei campi profughi,
se trasformi questi numeri in persone
la tua coscienza parla di più.
Io volevo dare un volto a questi numeri.
Bene, viviamo nelle tende.
Tra l’altro primi giorni non
era possibile vivere così
perchè avevamo una tenda
igloo e c’era la neve
quindi ci hanno ospitato
loro stessi in casa.
Abbiamo provato a vivere come loro
e cercare di capire la situazione
e il dramma del galleggiare,
sopravvivere era all’ordine del giorno.
C’era Abu Mariam, una donna
che aveva problemi di cuore,
il cui marito aveva perso le gambe
nella guerra in Siria,
una scheggia gli aveva fatto perdere
entrambe le gambe.
E lei non poteva lavorare,
non poteva fare sforzi
però doveva portare avanti
tutta la famiglia e i figli
e quindi andava a lavoro
tutti i giorni nei campi
a raccogliere patate,
pomodori, quello che c’era.
A volte la pagavano, a volte no.
E con questi soldi cercava
di mandare avanti la famiglia.
Un giorno sotto il sole non ce l’ha fatta,
il cuore non ha resistito, ed è morta.
E tuttora la famiglia
fa fatica a tirare avanti,
i bambini non vanno più a scuola
per cercare di portare
un po’ di cibo a casa.
C’era anche Mariam, una donna
con due bambini talassemici.
Tutti i mesi doveva cercare
il sangue da dare ai propri figli.
Ogni mese era una lotta contro il tempo
a cercare il sangue del proprio
gruppo sanguigno nei campi profughi
perché altrimenti non riusciva a cambiarlo
in tempo e i bambini potevano morire.
Le abbiamo proposto di arrivare in Italia
tramite dei corridoi umanitari l’ONU
ma lei non voleva
perché aspettava suo marito.
Suo marito era nelle carceri siriane e lì,
quando non hai notizia da più di due anni,
sicuramente li hanno ammazzati.
Però lei aveva comunque quel 5%
di speranza che il marito potesse tornare,
quindi era tutta una lotta
contro il tempo.
Abbiamo portato in ospedale
una bambina che stava per morire
e ci hanno detto: “Ci serve sangue A+”
Era il gruppo sanguigno di mio collega
l’abbiamo chiamato chiedendogli
di correre in ospedale.
Quando è arrivato, in tempo
per donare il sangue, il dottore ci fa:
“Non c’è tempo di fare le analisi,
andiamo a fiducia, però ho una domanda:
voi siete Italiani di Venezia, Firenze,
com’è che state qua? Chi ve lo fa fare!”
E lì ci hanno detto: “Basta, la vita
nei campi profughi non è possibile.
Vogliamo prendere
il Mar Mediterraneo e partire”.
Quando ho sentito “nel Mediterraneo”,
e quindi rischiare la vita nei barconi,
ho detto che non si poteva fare,
perché in quel momento per me
erano delle persone,
erano dei nomi, e non più dei numeri.
Li abbiamo fermati e abbiamo cercato
un’alternativa al Mediterraneo.
Abbiamo aperto dei corridoi umanitari
quindi la gente è arrivata con degli aerei
in Italia, in maniera protetta e sicura.
Dando a queste persone speranza
per un mondo diverso in maniera dignitosa.
Da lì il Mar Mediterraneo,
che avete visto nel video.
Il dramma a pochi chilometri
dalle nostre coste.
Sono partito perché non volevo
stare fermo per quello che sta accadendo
perchè prima o poi le future
generazioni ci chiederanno di questo,
di quello che sta accadendo
e quello che abbiamo visto tutti i giorni.
Ecco, la domanda che non
mi farebbe dormire la notte è:
che possiamo fare in tutto ciò?
Se le future generazioni mi diranno:
“Gennaro, dov’eri in tutto ciò?
Non hai fatto nulla per fermarlo?”
Un po’ come è successo nell’Olocausto,
per noi è follia che sia successo.
Ecco, il dover dire: “Ero a casa
senza far nulla” non mi farebbe dormire,
per questo sono partito.
La domanda che faccio a tutti è:
cosa possiamo fare in tutto ciò?
E se fosse mia sorella,
se fosse mio fratello
che fosse lì a rischiare la propria vita?
Grazie.